we start with cyclo the skipping cars
this might seem like it's frivolous but
it's not this is genius it could solve a
lot of problems with hawking this video
completely perplexes me I don't
understand how a car is able to jump
rope to find out more we travel to San
Antonio Texas to meet Gilbert Gonzales
Cyclones creator a lot of people have
said it can't be real there's no way
it's got to be photoshopped
I've seen a lot of cars I've built a lot
of cars but I've never seen a car that
could skip rope like this we try to do
things differently by showing the
impossible can be possible
yes Gilbert's modified car can jump
nearly 12 feet in the air so how can a
car jump that high Gilbert has done
three things first of all is reinforce
the frame of the car
second is taking the engine out so the
cars as light as possible the third
thing is done is to replace the
traditional suspension Springs with air
Springs you can think of those like
rubber bags that you can fill with air
which will lift the car up and take the
air out which will lower the car down
the next thing he put on board is eight
air tanks what they are is they're all
connected to the air Springs with valves
that he controls with a remote control
when he opens the valves on the air
tanks all the air rushes in really
quickly into the air Springs so what's
gonna happen these these Springs are
gonna fill with air very quickly they're
gonna push down against the ground
grounds not going anywhere the grounds
gonna push back and the cars gonna leap
into the air once the car lands the
weight of the car pushes the air out of
the air Springs through non-return
exhaust valleys this means the cars
ready to jump again in about 1.3 seconds
which makes it perfect for skipping
I wonder how Gilbert's gonna sell this
car he's gonna have to say it's had one
crazy owner and it's not a good one at
all it's a good skipper